It was a truly wacky weekend, uh, out of the
White House, Donald Trump suffering a bizarre
and strange meltdown over a story from the
Washington Post about tweets.
And it caused them to send out even crazier
tweets.
So on Saturday, The Washington Post wrote
about Donald Trump's racist tweets on Sunday,
almost like a full day later, Trump spent
his morning losing his mind over the Washington
Post story.
And one of the themes of that Washington Post
article, which was extensively sourced despite
the tweets you're about to see, Washington
Post did a really good job.
26 White House aids advisers, lawmakers and
others who were involved in handling Trump's
response to the hole, go back to their original
countries fiasco, basically shared the same
perspective with the Washington Post.
And the perspective was Trump didn't and doesn't
even understand why what he said and did was
controversial and problematic.
Like the guy just genuinely doesn't get it.
Uh, The Washington Post story tweeted Donald
Trump about my speech in North Carolina and
tweet with it's phony sources who do not exist
is fake news.
The only thing people were talking about is
the records setting crowd and the tremendous
enthusiasm far greater than the Democrats
you'll see in 2020.
So the North Carolina rally he's referring
to is that rally where the crowd chanted,
send her back.
When Donald Trump mentioned ethnic minority,
congresswoman Ilhan Omar a and Trump stood
there looking quite pleased and making no
effort to interrupt it, which will play an
important role later on in the show.
Then on Sunday morning, Donald Trump tweeted,
quote, presidential harassment, which is Trump's
codeword for a free press reporting about
what the president does and as an integral
and key part of our system of government,
not an institution that we should be attacking.
That's, that's what Trump means when he says
presidential harassment.
He doesn't like a free press.
And then a couple of minutes later, Donald
Trump tweeting again quote, I don't believe
the for Congress women are capable of loving
our country.
They should apologize to America and Israel
for the horrible, hateful things they have
said.
They are destroying the Democrat party, but
are weak and insecure people who can never
destroy our great nation.
So let's explore this for what it is.
When Trump calls something fake news, that
is a statement that is of no value.
Trump has said, he's admitted that fake news
is news he doesn't like or news that is critical
of him, so that ship has sailed.
Calling something fake news is of no meaning
or value whatsoever.
The problem is that the meme of fake news
has metastasized.
We have a poll which shows that 42% of Republicans
believe that a story that is accurate but
critical of the president is quote, fake news.
That's the crisis.
That's one of the crises.
The other crisis is that once again, the constant
and never ending misunderstandings about free
speech and censorship, and then most importantly
in this case for us, press freedom are truly
damaging to our democracy.
Free speech does not mean freedom from the
consequences of speech.
I've said this before, many of you will find
it repetitive.
Donald Trump seems to think that he can say
outrageous, racist, xenophobic things and
that for it to be free speech, it has to be
immune from any consequences, which includes
media writing stories about it.
The speech that is people and media reacting
to Trump Trump and what Trump says is just
as important as Donald Trump's speech itself.
It's arguably more important.
I would actually argue because Trump has the
power and the influence of the bully pulpit
as president of the United States.
It's the role of people.
It's the role of voters.
It's the role of media to counter act those
things when necessary or desirable.
Lastly, as usual, Donald seemingly very wound
up by lots of bad things going on for him
this week.
That is another, you know, in the back of
all these things, when you look at the timing,
it took 24 hours for Donald Trump to start
tweeting about this Washington Post article.
Y will, it was Sunday going into what may
not be a good week for Donald Trump.
Robert Mueller is scheduled to testify Wednesday.
We will see if that ultimately happens.
Every indication that it will, and obviously
Donald Trump is panicking documents from the
original Jeffrey Epstein case may be unsealed
and it's likely that Trump figures in those
documents.
Number three, the Iran fiasco has just completely
imploded on Trump and Trump has now been personally
implicated in hush money payments and some
newly released documents.
So it's not been a good week.
It's shaping, shaping up to be a very bad
week for Donald Trump.
And we have to understand that every time
these tweets storms happen that seem to make
not much sense, especially when it's been
like a full day.
Could have been that he saw something on Fox
News that reminded him of it.
Don't want to, uh, you know, ignore that possibility.
But there is almost always a scandal that
Donald Trump is eager to distract from an
unhinged tweets to take control of the new
cycle are a common way that he tries to do
that.
Make sure you are following me on Instagram
at David Dot Packman I posted a little video
of our number of youtube subscribers slowly
climbing.
We're set to hit 700,000 youtube subscribers
today.
Check that out on my Instagram.
And while you're there, follow the show on
Instagram at David Pakman.
Show